toi tout ce que tu mérites c'est ça
[Musique]
- on a tous quelque chose en nous ne te
laisses volonté de prolonger la nuit
d es fou de vivre une autre vie je rêve
en nous avec ses mots à lui les choses
de telle que vous avez m ouais ouais
ouais ouais c'était comment la laponie 3
mais pas trop froid
sur une différence de niveau entre les
compteurs sont les mêmes auteurs ils
comprennent la panique est en moi
j'étais rêver tous les matins par yossef
enfin mon sport à temps de ne pas
déroger à mon avis c'était après il ya
un problème c'est tout les jours 3
heures par
14h36 heures de travail tu te rases à
gauche tu vas pas vite capable il te
raser à droite il fait déjà nuit
commence à tâter maxime la laponie et
ses deux soeurs du jour de lumière par
jour des années a pas de coiffeur à quoi
sert donc on a pas de lumière
alors donc à 14h nombre total à endormir
a tout le temps alors il avait la
laponie coups du meneur
avoir une couleur mal tout seul j'ai
fait de la colocation et caroline
ithurbide prévoir et entre femmes
ce soir hier du malg belle famille comme
quoi
[Musique]
ça va marcher
jusqu'à tuer mais belle blonde un peu
comment ça va je suis césar ce soir je
me sens fort des watts équipe et je
viens
[Musique]
elle est donc moins vendra sûrement
s'estomper ces symboles sont majorés
[Musique]
je